acheter du pain frit ou décroissant
faire ses courses de nouveau une
habitude pour ses habitants de cruzy le
châtel cette épicerie est ouverte depuis
un mois elle a déjà changé le quotidien
de la petite commune on l'attendait avec
impatience parce qu'on a eu dans le
temps une épicerie une boulangerie puis
là ça faisait un certain temps qu'on
avait pu rien du tout comme commerce et
plus rien sur les métiers l'âge comme ça
on a dix minutes d'une épicerie donc oui
ça n'est pas notée sur des fois on
oublier quelques jours que l'on fait des
commerces et en vient à la maison et on
n'est pas obligé d'aller et venir aux
villes pour pour les commerces
on peut finir ici c'est bien ça situé au
coeur du bourg cette épicerie est le
seul commerce
la commune est propriétaire des murs
qu'elle a réhabilité elle loue aussi un
logement et a su convaincre isabelle
roble de reprendre cette affaire j'avais
ouvert en commerces en ville mais ça
m'intéresse pas sa matière mois voilà je
préfère autant faire un service aps les
gens qui sont à mobilité réduite ou qui
peuvent pas faire des kilomètres avec
des voitures pour pour les servir le
contact humain la vie à la campagne
c'est aussi ce qui a séduit brigitte
moreau elle a repris cet autre épicerie
toujours dans le ton est roi à châtel
gérard là encore la commune a initié le
projet est financé plus de 300000 euros
de travaux
gd le choix du conseil municipal de
garder une épicerie au village afin
d'apporter un peu de l'animation sombre
des clients savoir de la vie au village
certain confort aux habitants
c'est un cervicales parce que on est à
12 km de la première baguette de pain
deux premiers commerces à châtel gérard
l'épicerie n'est ouverte que depuis dix
jours mais les projets ne manquent pas
au printemps une terrasse devrait voir
le jour et invité les habitants à sortir
de chez eux